bonsoir entre les deux lexsi poulin et
eric verhaegue quand vous voyez ces
manifestations on ignore encore le
nombre de personnes qu'elles ont
rassemblé en plein confinement couvre
feu
finalement on se dit que ce mouvement
n'est peut-être pas terminée alexis
poulain il ya quand même beaucoup de
colère et notamment autour de cette loi
sur la sécurité globale qui concentre un
petit peu les crispations
quel cadeau pour les deux ans de ce
mouvement des filets jaunes que fait ce
régime de la république en marche
d'offrir une loi qui ferait de la france
le seul pays d'europe à interdire de
filmer finalement les policiers y
compris par les journalistes qui
seraient inquiétés dans l'exercice de
leur métier en violation totale de la
charte de munich ou des lois sur la
liberté de la presse qui sont en vigueur
dans notre démocratie libérale voilà un
résumé parfait de la façon dont le
pouvoir actuel envisage le dialogue et a
peur de la rue au point de réprimer par
la violence y compris les mouvements
lycéens de jeunes lycéens qui occupent
leur lycée pour que des protocoles
sanitaires soient mis en place pour
éviter qu'ils attrapent ce fameux virus
dont on ne les protège pas tant que ça
finalement parce qu'il ne serait pas
mise en danger alors vraiment voilà où
nous en sommes arrivés c'est à dire que
la contestation et il faut saluer les
gens qui sont aujourd'hui dans la rue
pour lutter contre cette loi de sécurité
globale qui est une loi de surveillance
globale qui sont les veilleurs de notre
démocratie avec le conseil des droits de
l'homme de l'onu beaucoup
d'organisations des droits de l'homme
mais également la défenseur des droits
qui a jugé cette loi extrêmement
dangereuses pour nos libertés pour la
liberté de la presse en particulier
donc je crois que seul maintenant les
derniers soutiens à la république en
marche ne voient pas le danger que
représente le gouvernement pour nos
libertés fondamentales de lois
d'exception loi d'exception de loi
sanitaire ubuesque en absurdistan
autoritariste voilà à quoi nous en
sommes réduits et heureusement la rue
n'est pas déserter malgré la violence
développer
doctrine par le ministre de l'intérieur
le gouvernement des mêmes actes éric
verhaeghe
c'est vrai que lazare ou pas du
calendrier en tout cas des deux ans de
ce mouvement d gilet jaune coïncide avec
cette loi de sécurité globale qui est
une forme de réponse aussi ces
manifestations qui ont été longuement
filmé et diffusé critiqué ce qu'on doit
les prendre comme cela moi je veux dire
je suis moins inquiet par cette
disposition de la loi qui je crois est
contenue dans l'article 24 que par
l'article 21 qui de mon point de vue est
encore plus beaucoup plus liberticides
puisqu'il prévoit la possibilité
d'équiper les drones de caméras qui
transmettront les données filmé en temps
direct au poste de commandement
ce qui permettra de faire de la
reconnaissance faciale immédiate des
manifestants
et je pense d'une certaine façon je le
dis avec une présence d'une provocation
amical que cette question du droit de
diffuser les images de policiers
elle est en réalité un peu secondaire
par rapport à la question du droit de
filmer les manifestants et de les
reconnaître en direct individuellement
facialement notamment en faisant
survoler les manifestations par des
drones et petit à petit on va
s'apercevoir que la surveillance par les
drones équipés de caméras avec des
systèmes de reconnaissance sociale va
s'étendre à l'ensemble du territoire
manifestations ou pas et je crains qu'il
y ait de ce point de vue beaucoup plus
de menaces sur les libertés que ce
simple article 24 qui déjà en soi est
très inquiétant je ne conteste
absolument pas et je souscris à ce qu'a
dit alexis poulain sur le sujet merci en
tout cas à vous deux